team jackson what's happening you
pettiest come on
steve jackson what's happening what's
happening
let those who have an ear let them hear
you came for gossip i came with the
gospel
you came to blame i came to slay with
the power of the holy spirit
and i take authority as my master has
given me
because behold i have seen satan fall
like lightning
i have given you authority to trample
over snakes and scorpions and to
overcome all
the powers of darkness nothing by any
means shall
harm you and i come trampling over
snakes and scorpions and to overcome all
the powers of
of darkness that wants to suck up
marriage and divide the house of god and
divide the
men and women of god from each other
some of you don't understand this
because you don't have
kingdom thinking you don't know kingdom
principles and you don't know how to act
and walk in kingdom why she dressed like
she ready for a major laser video
to not operate from your lowest self
whatever it may be
so when i looked in the comments of this
video
i don't know if old boy was trolling or
not but he said d
i think i want to see a reaction to this
video so
let's do it and by the way i'm gonna
speak in third person um a lot of you
already seen this but
stop okay listen you're not a batman
villain i don't know
i don't know you're not the riddler i
don't know why you're trying to speak
about yourself in third person
get yourself a publicist bro when the
person said whoa
said why don't you react to this he was
why do i have to explain this just
because someone said it doesn't mean
that you should do it
okay this is one of those times where uh
someone take their phone away this is
one of those times yeah
please take this man's phone away this
is derek jackson
a lot of people think of him as a
relationship expert and guru and all of
that well
he and his wife are making this video
because apparently at some point in
their marriage or maybe even beforehand
in a relationship
he didn't take his own advice and he
stepped out and got involved with other
women as you heard
you know what this is like bro
this is like when you go to an open mic
and somebody doesn't know they can't
sing
and they start belting it out hitting
all those
i will always laugh
well always left
[Music]
thank you guys for coming out hope you
guys enjoyed it they come see you
afterwards so how was it
[ __ ] are you that lacking in
self-awareness that you couldn't tell
this was stupid
really bro you can't fix this oh my god
you can't fix this
okay you can't fix this the horse is
dead
she'll never ride again because this
whole like
i found god stick and now that i've got
god back in my life and my wife is with
me and
i i'm reacting to myself to understand
myself i'm so self
no one's buying it even jesus he's not
answering your calls
i really like when charlotte man the god
said first name first name [ __ ] last
name please
that's right it's my whole sentiment
and all this started when you look down
on other people
the hypocrisy we love to watch
hypocrites burn we love it
we love it when the pastor says all
these anti-gay stuff and he turns out to
be
we love it like that guy in poland that
was like a politician that was super
now upon first impression nothing really
stuck out to me about him but more so
about the wife
but just by her body language i was
really wondering like did he force her
to do this video
like she looks super uncomfortable like
she doesn't want to be there but then i
watched their live chat that they did
right afterwards and
you know i kind of caught that this is
just a part of her personality so that
kind of explains
somewhat of her demeanor you know she
clearly has a mind
you're explaining the explanation you
know what this is like bro
you know what this is what is it this is
like the police investigating themselves
after a murder
yeah i think we did a good job boys hey
we've investigated ourselves and we've
cleared ourselves of all wrongdoing
[ __ ] what yes that's exactly that's
what this is that's what this is good
but you know what when the police do it
they know what they're doing
they're trying to cover their ass you my
friend you seem to really believe this
[ __ ]
anyway you try to curse his ass anyways
he's lost it you know she clearly has a
mind of her own if you saw the live chat
too
and she said that live chat even was her
idea um so with that
you know can you imagine if your
daughter got kidnapped by somebody
and then that person sent you a video
like yeah me and her talked and she
loves being here
would you believe the kidnapper not a
word
now regardless whether you like them
love them or hate them i think this is a
great example as to why
we don't need to be putting anybody on
the pedestal nobody and i think a lot of
women did that and i'm not even going to
say it's the women's fault by themselves
because
this dude he never really showed his
struggle you know we understand oh we're
all humans and we all make mistakes but
he never showed those mistakes not for
real i think he wrote about it
it's not it's not it's not that you
didn't show your struggle or your
mistakes
is that you clown peop not clown
but you demonize people for doing the
same mistakes that you did
you didn't say that but it makes it puts
you in a position that you're better
than them
i like how this man's gaslighting his
fans into saying you guys are the reason
i was idealized no
you definitely encouraged it you
definitely encourage and you're
definitely a big reason
you basically had a whole platform that
basically said
but i'm not like the other guys that was
your whole platform
but i'm not like them dudes you were
queen you were crowned
and i'm not like those guys that was
your plan you should have been on a
bachelor not only because somebody can
be living a double life which i don't
think is quite the case here according
to his wife
behind the scenes without anybody
knowing of course this part ain't gonna
blow up
but he's been putting into work to kind
of reconstruct where that all had been
broken since last year so i don't think
it's a double life thing but
i'm more so on the side of his wife and
just basically letting this be a new
chapter of how i see him
because i do believe that his content
over the years has helped a tremendous
amount of people
you know he tells the truth he speaks
facts i appreciate how he constantly is
giving himself compliments throughout
this whole thing
just want to say this is devolving very
fast my friend
i now understand why this man deleted
this video
reporting he's been completely honest um
some people are just going to close the
book on d
some people are going to close the book
on this dude and say you know what i'm
done with you
cancel you cancel culture come here
y'all let me know what you think down in
the comments and by the way
he has a book detailing how he and his
wife overcame all of this in their
private lives
all right this is too cringy i can't
watch anymore i'm gonna just stop it
right there
go ahead preach
none of this would have mattered and it
still doesn't but you broke people
when you're doing books and you're
having seminars and you're having people
that you're talking to directly
and you're changing the life you should
do this you should do that because men
are like this and like that
derek jackson that his business talking
to women
and shifting the weight basing on what
he lives that's what derek did
that's the only thing that derek did
that's his main business
influencing people look here's his book
that's how i do in my marriage and your
marriage is
it's not it's a lie but you're based the
fact is that you base yourself in your
book
on the lie that you're saying i'm
starting to feel a little bit bad
because i think this man is legitimately
having a breakdown i think like mentally
this man is not well anymore um you i
don't
what i know what i know this you petty
that you
you he's petty please let him know he's
petty
i mean yeah it's good content though i'm
definitely petty but i'm i'm
legitimately thinking this man in his
head is just not doing well i am mad at
you like if you woke up tomorrow and he
self-deleted i wouldn't be surprised
i'm to that point because my by here
my suspicion i hear you people are
saying he's a narcissist and all that
stuff i don't actually think it said you
know what i think it is
i think there's the man he wants to be
and the man he knows himself to be
and now that people are completely
disillusioned with this he's having to
he's trying to hold on to this and the
world's like no [ __ ] we see you
and i think that because i've seen other
men who've been clown cheating scandals
and they
spiral worse than this about why is
like what
it shouldn't matter but because yeah
that's the thing
but when you live a life for so long my
[ __ ] the things that you're gonna do to
try to maintain that lie
i mean we got this man reacting to
himself and he's talking about himself
in the third person
[ __ ] that is how far he's trying to
take the lie
because when you've built an image for
that long the things you will do to keep
hold of this
crazy so i think he's legitimately
losing it
he included it in his business and so
people i've i've seen
i've seen comments oh
because he used that to to dictate other
people's life and people
listen to him yeah it's not even just
him seeing the comments like
i had a whole man that i left because
and he she gonna take and i understand
why people are mad that's right
when you make it to your business and
you try to sound righteous yeah
nobody's perfect but when you're trying
to look down on people
if you guys have seen that me mean if
you or one of your loved ones
has been negatively affected by one of
jared jackson's videos
you may be allowed some compensation